obviously perception wise as a kid you
don't I didn't associate a Green Lantern
and Immortal even though it makes sense
like musically and it was dope but yeah
I think it like like you said like you
pointed out so much stuff
early because again at that time we
didn't have access to YouTube and like
jumping down a rabbit hole and it's like
wait a minute what is he talking about
like you know I think um
I think that you definitely uh you know
in terms of
shedding the light to a whole generation
of kids who are just hip-hop heads you
definitely did open their eyes to a lot
of wild shipment and a lot of truthful
[ __ ] right and also I think that even to
this day there's songs that I've written
that people still ask me questions about
like I'm not gonna lie Kev even 20 years
later people ask me is Dance with the
Devil a true story and I have to look
these people right in the eye and say
sir I am not responsible for raping or
killing any women that is absolutely
crazy it is a song however yeah I can
take people if they really want to the
building where this incident happened in
Harlem and the truth is that that
actually did happen and those people
that were allegedly responsible for that
began dying and that's why it became
such a powerful story because everyone's
like oh you're telling Hood Tales what
if these [ __ ] come back for you
and I said let them right what they're
gonna do like you think that the
neighborhood is going to protect them
after they find out what they really did
that they raped a woman do you realize
that in rich communities you can get
away with stuff like that you know oh
they're little kids coming in all hours
in the night no one says anything about
billionaires but if you live in the
ghetto and someone says a rumor in the
hood oh someone's touching kids in
apartments
everybody from the neighborhood
so that's the kind of energy it was and
these people literally started dying and
one of them
I I we're not going to mention names
because these people don't deserve to be
remembered in a good light but this is a
sad story they couldn't find this man
and I what I explained to people about
the street is that there's no there's no
rules just like there's no such thing as
a safe gun you have to respect
everything I'm a big Second Amendment
guy you have to respect the weapon
there's no such thing as a safe gun
these people were out here thinking that
they could get away with a crime and
that they wouldn't be found and they
murdered this man's son to get him to
come to the funeral so they could kill
him
this is the type of [ __ ] that people
were dealing with that's one of your
would you say that's your most popular
song it's like one of them right
probably yeah
um for people who because there's gonna
be people watching this YouTube video
who subscribe who who maybe are not hip
to your catalog give us a break like for
people who haven't heard Dance with the
Devil what is the premise of the record
well I mean without giving the entire
thing away I would say that
um it's definitely a very realistic tale
of what happens when people feel peer
pressured to commit violence to join a
gang or when they feel like they have to
overcompensate for not being as tough as
everybody thinks they is and they commit
violence and do horrible things to
people to try to prove something to
somebody I remind individuals that are
really living in the street we don't
deal with gratuitous violence we deal
with people that have offended or hurt
us who have come into our neighborhood
and cause problems the premise of going
into another neighborhood and just
trying to hurt people right doesn't make
sense now I mean even if you ask the
essays that run each Block they'll be
like why would I start a war for no
reason but in New York City it was
structured differently it wasn't so much
gangs it was Crews back in New York
right right so if you heard about a
story like this it became an urban
legend immediately and not just that Kev
it was that
the story was always a little bit
different instead of it being the guy's
mom it would be the person's stepsister
it would be the aunt it would be someone
related and I think when you have tales
about you know Murder or killing people
it's a grandized some sometimes in
hip-hop to the point that you never
really see the impact of what that is
like even if y'all kill someone that's
not a kid if y'all kill someone that's
30 years old you think that's not
somebody's son of course you don't think
you have a Target on your back right you
don't think that somebody's coming back
for you that's the reality then and more
often than not when people come up to me
and they say oh do you think the guys
from Dance with the Devil were really
cursed by the devil and I'm like no they
lived a horrible lifestyle where they
thought they could get away with hurting
people at random and eventually it
catches up not just to them but to their
children as well